both of you here for sightseers both
nominated for awards obviously very very
excited 90 having spoken to Alice T for
you kind of had a little caravanning
holiday yourselves didn't you to get in
the right places before and tell me what
happens and we found out that we hate
each other we wrote it down that becomes
the film no it was quite an important
sort of a process actually for us to go
through because we wanted the film had
to be really it had to come from real
experiences I had to come from real
locations and it had to come from a real
camping experience as well so we really
wanted to try and go method with it and
sort of and also use real British
locations which I think looks stunning
in the film so it was really important
for us to all the locations really you
know when we went there we kind of went
oh man these are these are places where
certain scenes would happen and it was
really useful great yeah Lee very
atmospheric isn't it in terms how it
looks and in the landscape answer I
wanted to know what are you guys going
to be thinking of doing next using this
as a launch pad because obviously it's a
fantastic one you know everyone's live
to fill it had great reviews more more
films more films please yes please
written and project separately actually
that are sort of we're looking to film
next year
that's really exciting and I think you
know we kind of in our wildest dreams
thought we would get to do more so it's
just too exciting for us what can we
expect from you well mine's kind of a
genre mashup kind of thing it's a
domestic drama that has fantasy
sequences in it was about a bored
housewife who's got fantasy world so
hopefully as me getting a chance to try
out lots of different things mine's a
butt is it's about a guy a guy in his
[ __ ] brother who go go off to kill
someone and they're not very good at it
so it's kind of a buddy movie really
you